[Musica]
oggi siamo qui per parlare di limiti
il mio è solo apparentemente semplice ed
a rispondere alle sue provocazioni
l'ultima circa due settimane fa mi si
avvicina mi guarda e mi dice padre sì
perché detto tra di noi
lui si rivolge così a me il suo boomer
di fiducia in questi termini del passato
come padre quando in realtà vorrebbe
semplicemente dire ma che ne sai è
comunque padre tu che lavori
nell'intelligenza artificiale ma quindi
in futuro le macchine ci domineranno
eccolo qua il domandone realtà questa
non è una domanda recente ma è un
quesito che da tempo accompagna alla
nostra evoluzione
e sì perché siamo sempre stati
caratterizzati da due desideri primo la
possibilità di creare qualcosa di dare
vita di portare il nostro se fuori da
noi
secondo il desiderio di superarsi di
avere qualcosa o qualcuno che ci
aiutasse nell'andare oltre i nostri
limiti cognitivi o fisici ma insieme a
questi due desideri c'è sempre stato un
timore
una paura che tutto questo potere
potesse improvvisamente sfuggirci di
mano e diventare incontrollabile
proviamo a tornare indietro nel tempo a
calarci nei panni dei nostri avi
siamo ad esempio nella tradizione
ebraica c'è in quel periodo si parlava
del golem un gigante d'argilla creato
dall'uomo senza alcuna intelligenza ma
dotato di una forza fisica disumana
pronto a soddisfare tutte le nostre
esigenze
ma ecco che insieme al desiderio del
golem era nata al timore la paura che
questi giganti potessero diventare
sempre più grandi
tanto che non solo sarebbe stato
impossibile servirsene
ma sarebbero diventati una minaccia
possiamo poi in epoca più recente
all'introduzione delle macchine
all'interno della catena di montaggio
siamo nel periodo della rivoluzione
un industriale un'epoca di profondi
cambiamenti in cui per la prima volta
viene messo in discussione il legame
uomo macchina ed è proprio in questo
periodo che mary shelley scrive
frankenstein il mostro dalle sembianze
umane testimone all'epoca del nostro
scetticismo nei confronti della
tecnologia e dal mostro di frankenstein
ha preso poi vita la sindrome di
frankestein che ancora oggi è testimone
della nostra paura del nostro timore che
le creature le nostre creazioni possano
in qualche modo ribellarsi oggi poi con
l'intelligenza artificiale con la
moderna robotica la domanda di mio
figlio si ripropone un timore alimentato
anche da una cultura popolare e dai film
di hollywood pensiamo il robot
terminator ex machina 2001 odissea nello
spazio che disegnano un futuro in cui il
mondo sarà governato dalle macchine ma
dalla stessa scienza che ci sta dicendo
che da oggi al 2030 le macchine
inizieranno a pensare come gli esseri
umani
e sì perché se è vero che l'intelligenza
artificiale e qualcosa nata ben 60 anni
fa oltremodo indubbio che i suoi
benefici la sua adozione ha avuto una
crescita esponenziale solo in questi
ultimi anni e ha cambiato radicalmente
la nostra quotidianità
il nostro modo di vivere il nostro modo
di lavorare il nostro modo di studiare
semplicemente il nostro modo di
relazionarsi con gli altri
siamo oggi circondati da strumenti
sempre più intelligenti in grado di
interagire con noi che ci aiutano a
superare i nostri limiti cognitivi se
pensiamo l'intelligenza artificiale
piuttosto che fisici
se pensiamo alla moderna robotica e
allora proviamo a parcheggiare un attimo
i dubbi di fronte a questa tecnologia e
concentriamoci un attimo su quelli che
sono i nostri benefici pensiamo ad
esempio ai recenti problemi sulle nostre
strade ed autostrade
pensate abbiamo più di un milione e
mezzo di strade più di un milione di
ponti centinaia di gallerie
ma che cosa accadrebbe sia l'esperienza
dei nostri manutentori e dei nostri
ingegneri si affiancassero delle
macchine in grado di analizzare i
miliardi di dati provenienti dal manto
autostradale
magari tramite rilevamenti aerei di
droni e ci aiutassero non solo nella
pagni pianificazione della manutenzione
ma addirittura nel rilevare in tempo
reale delle anomalie e garantire un
pronto intervento
beh sicuramente riusciremo ad anticipare
se non a eliminare del tutto i problemi
di sicurezza delle nostre strade come
cambierebbe poi il nostro sentire se i
medici oggi in tempi brevi riuscissero a
trovare una cura e una diagnosi ad una
malattia che sino a ieri non aveva
neanche un nome
quante vite potremmo salvare
e questo un futuro oggi possibile grazie
a medici affiancati da sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale in grado di
analizzare le oltre 18 milioni di
pubblicazioni in ambito tecnico
scientifico insieme ai miliardi di dati
provenienti dalle cartelle cliniche dei
pazienti di tutto il mondo
e poi come ci sentiremmo se un nostro
caro un nostro amico che era privato
degli arti tornarsi a camminare con noi
oggi esoscheletri protesi robotiche arti
artificiali ci hanno disegnato degli
scenari impensabili sino a qualche
decennio fa
siamo di fronte una vera e propria
rivoluzione che ci sta trasformando i
moderni superman
ecco che allora di fronte a tutti questi
benefici la nostra domanda iniziale le
macchine ci domineranno ma che cosa
vuole dirci forse ci stiamo chiedendo
qual è il limite che non vogliamo
superare per cercare di superare i
nostri limiti
ci stiamo forse chiedendo se da qua i
prossimi anni saremo costantemente
impegnati in un braccio di ferro
l'uomo macchina no
la tecnologia la macchina in quanto tale
è un mezzo il cui fine è il nostro
benessere
tra l'altro le macchine non sono neanche
così intelligenti come sembrano
seguitemi
il sistema di intelligenza artificiale
apprendono sì è vero ma siamo noi che
diciamo loro quello che devono imparare
sistema di intelligenza artificiale non
hanno la consapevolezza di quello che
stanno imparando non hanno neanche la
consapevolezza di quello che stanno
facendo una macchina che ci batte
giocando a scacchi non sa che sta
giocando a scacchi che noi non sa
neanche che sta giocando e tra l'altro
non si incavola neanche come faccio io
quando perdo il robot potranno stappare
meglio le bibite di quanto fanno i
nostri figli senza lasciare tutti i
tappi in giro ma non saranno mai in
grado di farci sentire il gusto della
nostra bevanda preferita
poi è vero le macchine oggi hanno
raggiunto un livello di evoluzione tale
per cui sono in grado di monitorare gli
umori delle persone intorno a noi ma non
sono certo in grado di provare nei
sentimenti una macchina non è in grado
di provare i miei i nostri sentimenti di
fronte a un meraviglioso tramonto o di
fronte ai quadri dei nostri pittori
preferiti o delle mirabolanti rovesciate
di pelè ieri e di cristiano ronaldo
oggi poi si è vero le macchine oggi
riescono a fare calcoli complessissimi
per la nostra mente in secondi ma cadono
sulla più banale delle cose farsi
domande le macchine non si chiedono se
una cosa ha senso o non ha senso o il
perché è una determinata domanda è
rivolta loro il continuare a farsi
domande a interrogarsi ad approfondire e
quello che oggi ci eviterà in futuro di
arrivare all universo distopico
disegnato dai film di hollywood
sì perché continuare a farsi domande e
quello che continuerà a farci agire per
ciò che è giusto e per il bene
dell'umanità quello che gli esperti
chiamano secondo i criteri di eticità
perché noi non dobbiamo innovare per il
gusto di creare qualcosa noi dobbiamo
innovare
e per il nostro bene semplicemente per
farmi fare meno coda di fronte a uno
sportello o per aiutarmi nella cura dei
miei cari malati di alzheimer e poi da
ultimo si le macchine potranno anche
aiutarci a prendere decisioni in maniera
più efficace così come gli arti robotici
potranno aiutarci ci aiutano a tornare a
camminare ragazzi ma non ci danno la
forza di volontà la determinazione di
superare la fatica dei primi passi o di
portare avanti le azioni che abbiamo
deciso quando i tempi si fanno cupi
quando i tempi si fanno buy
ecco che allora per tornare alla domanda
iniziale le macchine ci domineranno no
le macchine non ci domineranno il futuro
di una stretta collaborazione uomo
macchina ma soprattutto francesco i tuoi
limiti i miei limiti ei nostri limiti
noi non li superiamo grazie ad una
macchina ma li superiamo grazia noi
stessi grazie alla consapevolezza e
grazie alla forza di volontà e l'esempio
francesco forse è troppo vicino per
esserti evidente è la tua nonna
sì lei lei che nel 1953 all'età di 13
anni da bambina cadendo da una pianta è
ha perso un braccio
siamo negli anni del dopoguerra periodo
dell'adolescenza in cui vivere senza un
arto metteva in discussione tuo futuro
perché semplicemente non era più in
grado di aprire una bottiglia o di
scrivere figuriamoci poi l'idea di
trovare un marito trovare un lavoro
costruirsi una famiglia e costruire un
futuro è il suo superpotere beh non era
certo un arto robotico visto che aveva
questo con sé ma la consapevolezza dei
propri limiti e delle proprie
potenzialità e la forza di volontà
la forza di volontà di andare oltre di
riappropriarsi della propria libertà di
essere donna
la forza di volontà di riavere la
libertà di aprire una bottiglia
aiutandosi magari con le gambe di
tornare a scrivere con un altro arto di
studiare la notte per vincere concorsi
che le avrebbero permesso prima di
diventare una centralinista e poi una
segretaria di trovare un uomo come tuo
nonno francesco che l'avrebbe amata che
avrebbe superato i propri limiti per
amore di costruire una famiglia e dare
vita ad un futuro e il fatto figlio mio
che tu sia qua oggi con le tue
provocazioni
io sia qui a rispondere è la migliore
dimostrazione di tutto questo